this is thinking back to that fear is
there things you're afraid of
now i don't know what you're not doing
you're afraid to do
i'm afraid of all kinds of things i'm
afraid of not being good at my job not
being funny letting people down
uh not putting out products that are
good
you know whether it's the podcast every
week or stand up or the videos like i'm
afraid of like there's a ton of people
that really enjoy what we do
so when you're in that position you're
nervous that
you're going to start doing things that
they don't like so the new things you
want to do the
evolution you want to do you want to
make sure you're evolving in the right
way
you know you want to make sure that
you're doing things that are consistent
with why people liked you
but also you don't want to put yourself
in a box and limit
what you can be going forward so like i
had a talk with the ceo of nbc universal
once
i was doing some internal sketch for
them and
i was playing like a cab driver and he
was a and he's not the current ceo but
he's a former ceo and i said
what's the hardest part of running a
corporation of this size
and he said something very interesting
uh he said the hardest part is
maximizing the current
profit model of what you have at the
same time
getting ready getting ready getting the
company ready for where it's going to be
in five years
he said those are often at odds and
that's the toughest thing he goes
because i could just
bang out everything i got to do right
now and we're going to make a lot of
money doing this
but am i devoting enough resources in
the digital so that in five years when
that's where everything lives are we
competitive
in that space so it's funny as i am now
hopefully to people and
a lot of the things that i want to do
now i'm going what am i what groundwork
am i not laying
for three to five years down the road so
that i can be adapting
to the trends that are important then
in terms of not so much comedic trends
but like the
technological trends like what is the
what is it you know i should have done
podcasting earlier what should i
should i have a bigger presence on tick
tock should i have a bigger presence
here should i have a business or should
i be on twitch
should i be doing this should i be doing
that what am i not doing that i should
be doing that i'll regret not doing
and those are those are the
conversations i think i have in my own
head all the time and i guess there's
parallels to coming out as gay or just
parallels in in like uh career paths
you're taking
all that that's ultimately just fear
it's fear
yeah it's the fear of you know the the
best thing that happened in my career
was that i came to la
i didn't have an idea of what was gonna
happen
i met somebody who was really uh
committed to making funny things
that we just wanted to be funny no one
would let us be funny we didn't have
comedy central letting us be funny we
didn't have hbo we didn't have netflix
we just had a garage and a phone in the
beginning and then a camera
and then a thing and we just wanted to
be funny and that
was the greatest risk really i took
because i was like well
i don't know what else is going to
happen right now but i just want to be
funny
and funny saved my life right i mean
funny got me out of drugs funny probably
got me out of the closet funny was
the thing that i was able to do that
made everything okay in my own head so i
was like as long as i'm being funny
something good will happen so we did
that
and then something really cool happened
that we were able to do a lot of cool
things
but you know that's what it is it's fear
that keeps you from being the better
version of yourself
you